Porcia good divide inside the Democratic
Party moderates now facing threats and
political retribution if they work with
Republicans House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
reportedly scolding more than two dozen
Democrats who broke rank to support a
Republican amendment in a gun control
bill this week congresswoman Alexandria
Ocasio Cortes taken it a step further by
threatening to put those Democrats on a
list for a primary challenge if they
vote with the GOP in the future this is
very interesting because how did they
win in the midterms Gregg it wasn't
necessarily the left it was in those
moderate swing districts where they have
to be able to vote as her constituents
want I liked how you asked me that
question that you answered it I need to
rest my brain after beating Jessie
yesterday on Tucker it'll come up every
segment okay this strategy to your point
mistakingly gives the power to the very
people that they're trying to punish
suddenly moderates and kind of
independent minds have like the power of
ten of their peers like think about like
the freedom [ __ ] what's his name Rand
Paul every time there has to be a vote
everybody has to go to Rand Paul they
all have to run to Rand Paul and see
bran would you do this would you do that
and also swimmer Susan Collins with the
Cavanaugh thing it's great to be that
person the person that everybody has to
wonder and worry about I love stalemates
one of the great things about your
parents fighting is that they overlook
the stuff you're doing you know so you
could stay out later and they don't
notice in the liquor cabinet every
bottle got slightly less not as much as
I would have liked but so what I mean is
less work gets done in the government
with stalemate saleman stalemate it's
kind of its own form of limited
government right you see the stock
market is happier - yes the government's
not doing anything what do you like to
have been a fly on the wall at this
meeting Jessie yes definitely Dana yes
let's be honest here there is a
statistic in sports called plus or minus
oh yeah it's hard it measures the
players impact on the game when they're
on the bench and when they're okay on
the field and how the other team's
scoring on the opposing player sports
plating if you look at it
Republicans are scoring so many points
because of AOC if you think about the
green New Deal
socialism abolish ice and then being
okay with the legal immigrants crossing
the border to go buy guns and then not
telling anybody that the illegals are
trying to buy guns that is so crazy
if the Democrats lose the house in 2020
they're gonna be Democrats pointing
their finger at AOC and on top of that
she wants to create a civil war this is
like she's like the Steve banning of the
left now remember what happened with the
Tea Party you get some good candidates
like a Rubio or Cruz and then you get
your Aikens and you get some crazy
Cristina the witch I'm not a witch I'm
you right you know I love when Democrats
fight each other I just relax Jessi's
point take a look at this poll Kennedy
this was them in the Wall Street Journal
question about Medicare for all so in
November of 2018 when the election was
happening that was about 30% support
where is it today 12% a hell of a chart
what do you think about that chart yeah
I think it's a great chart thank you
excellent thank you
I mean I think because we're talking
about the issues rather than just about
personalities and and that's fantastic
but I think the problem with
progressives is they feel the the cult
of personality will sell the idea the
problem is you know voters are more
tuned in than they haven't in the past
because everyone is talking about
politics nowadays one of my bosses
pointed out that this is the new water
cooler it used to be the Kardashians and
now it's President Trump and Congress
and so people go one step further on a
lot of issues make a wait a second what
does this cost and that's how you know
Maria and I talked about this a lot
moderate Democrats who have made inroads
in the party in critical parts of the
country and Nancy Pelosi and aoc a brand
new freshman congresswoman is telling
them they have to vote in lockstep do
you think that's going to be popular
with our purple constituencies back home
no way if
a throw off the blob and show some
independence they are much more
electable and if I want this job for a
long time and by the way I don't know
who would want this job if you've got
people telling you if you don't vote a
certain way if you show any independence
or logic at all you're going on a list
that's a horrible job that's right and
congresswoman
Acacio cortez with her list apparently
congresswoman Torres small also a
freshman she won that seat in New Mexico
- and it was a very close race it's
right there on the border and apparently
she stood up in the meeting Marie and
she said you don't know how hard it is
to actually run in a district where it's
hard I mean obviously she knows he beat
the incumbent Democrat liberal if she
didn't have to run in a very tough and I
think Democrats are seeing a little bit
of what the Republicans went through and
they're still seeing it right you're
having very hardcore right-wing folks
threatening to primary Republicans
that's why so many moderate Republicans
didn't run in xx the straight because
they didn't want to get that kind of
inner party primary look these members
who won in 2018 the moderate Democrats I
do not think they are going to fall
lockstep in line with AOC and I don't
think AOC supporting primary challengers
and these in these districts will
actually work if we look at these
moderate districts or moderate states in
2018 the Democrats that won the
primaries were moderates they beat much
more progressive look at Virginia and
the governor's race for example tom
Perriello really progressive he was beat
by Ross he lost
so I I think that I bet you wish the
other guy had won but that's actually
been an interesting discussion Jesse but
no I think that AOC is very good at
getting people to talk about her the
question that will face voters is who's
done something for you and the moderate
Democrats I think have plans to say
here's what I voted on that would have
benefited you here's how I've tried to
help you and she is really mean she is
getting so much grief from inside the
party for threatening to primary people
when she's not done anything I think I
had something to that very quickly
Georgia has if you're talking about
moderate Democrats they're the ones who
are coming up with ideas to push forward
an agenda which is the opposite of what
Democratic leadership is doing
especially in the house they don't have
ideas they have resist
and even though Nancy Pelosi's grabbed
this other topic here because if there's
another example of liberal outrage Joe
Biden forced to apologize after making
this statement about Mike Pence the fact
of the matter is it was followed on by a
guy as a decent guy our voice president
who stood before this group of allies
and leaders and said I'm here on behalf
of President Trump there was dead
silence after receiving tons of backlash
for calling pence a decent guy Biden
backtracked tweeting in part quote there
is nothing decent about being anti LGBTQ
rights and that includes the vice
president so Greg can't even like say
someone's a nice guy even if you
disagree with them you know you can you
can believe that pence is incorrect in
his beliefs and but and still see Biden
as a really weak person because he
didn't change his mind he folded to a
mob on social media I mean if he gets
that easily spooked which is the
opposite of being a leader how is he
going to handle the Twitter mob or even
Trump in a debate I mean if you fold
that quickly Joe showed us Joe should
have said you know what pence was where
I was you know 15 years ago and do I
dislike who I was 15 years ago no I
thought it was a pretty good guy I still
think he's a pretty good guy it's also
interesting how one religion gets the
shaft a lot on this but another religion
doesn't let me make of that in terms of
I think that's a really good point if if
Joe Biden had said look it's a
leadership position if the number two
issue in the country is a worry about
polarization right is a way for him to
deal with it to be the leader that says
actually know what we can all do this we
can just for all Americans he came to
the resistance and you know my motto
Dana never apologize makes you look weak
and soft the art of the Jesse in 2020 it
has and in 2020 it's going to be the
Democrats who apologize for everything
and Trump who apologizes for nothing
so it's going to be a great clash into
Gregg's point Joe Biden was an indecent
man just five years ago or ten years ago
when he was had the same position on
traditional marriage it doesn't make
you anti LGBTQ don't have that right I
got it
if you're against traditional marriage
you can be Christian and not hate gay
people
like they're trying to smear pen size
and didn't the Trump administration just
push for a worldwide decriminalization
of homosexuality he doesn't get any
credit there Marie I think what this
lesson tells us is that what we are
seeing in many of these primary states
out on the road now that candidates are
talking to voters is that voters care
about a very different set of things
than the online Twitter mob and so if
people running in this primary want to
reach primary voters they cannot suck up
their time and energy doing what Gregg
says getting tied into the mob
responding to everything because when
you look at issues even like Elizabeth
Warren and the Native American issue
voters aren't asking her about it it's
so true and you know what a good
perspective because you're not on
Twitter I am NOT uh admire that so much
Kennedy a last word no I think Gregg and
Murray have it absolutely right you know
Gregg's right and fold to the mob and
and you cannot anticipate them and you
also cannot pacify them so don't even
try and this election is going to be
very different than 2016 it's not just
gonna be acrimonious Democrats have to
decide do they want a cheap pale
impression of President Trump and you
know to do the kind of things in sling
the kind of insults that they see right
or do they want someone who is actually
strong and can lead the country because
sometimes being strong means saying you
know what yeah I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna talk about identity politics every
time I open my mouth because again
you're not talking to the people who are
going to and just blazed that trail